not so special for
the san francisco 49ers there have
always been durability concerns when it
comes to the bosa brothers and nick bosa
suffered an ankle sprain in practice on
wednesday may not play at all in the
preseason he got an mri on wednesday
evening the 49ers gonna be cautious as
he works his way back from the injury
trying to get him ready for week one now
remember when his brother joey came out
three years ago from ohio state he he
was a holdout at this stage of the
calendar so uh it took him time to even
get in and then he did have some injury
issues and that's always been one of the
concerns and and like not to jinx
anybody we were talking about hey there
hasn't been a really big injury to a key
player that's knocked him out for the
season yet and for a while yesterday
there was some anxiety about
uh
nick bosa possibly having a serious
injury but uh for now
not serious but he's had two injuries he
hasn't played in the game
and uh
you're gonna hold your breath if you're
a 49ers fan especially because they
could have had quinn and williams and
and you know usually you see those
apples to apples comparisons with
quarterbacks or running backs or
receivers but when the 49ers had quinn
and williams on the board and there was
some buzz that maybe they were going to
take him that maybe he was the safer
pick
and remember all that that the off-field
stuff with both so not that he got in
any trouble but there was some concern
about political issues and would that
fly in san francisco and and that all
got pushed aside they went with the guy
who has the higher upside in their
estimation but it could be that quinn
and williams ends up being the guy that
uh that has the stronger
um
chance at least to make an impact right
away and d ford also has tendonitis in
his knee he's not available right now
and he here we are
the 49ers every time it feels like
they're trying to get the ducks in a row
to go out and have
a contending relevant team under kyle
shanahan this injury issue pops up and
it's popped up with various different
guys uh and and you know at a certain
point
it's no longer bad luck and i've said
this many times over the years i
remember it happened with the seahawks
10 years ago there's been issues at
times with teams like the chargers
when you have more injuries than you
should at a certain point it really
isn't just dumb luck
at a certain point you have to go back
and take a look at
your training strength programs you have
to look at your rehab you have to look
at everything is there something that
you're not doing or you or that you are
doing incorrectly that is setting the
stage for or contributing to these
injuries if you watch games on sunday
it's amazing how many guys you see get
all pretzeled up and and they're fine
they get up and they they walk away from
it a lot of that is a testament to the
things that their teams do to get them
ready to go out there and play and when
guys are getting injured all the time
that's when you really need to take a
closer look at what's going on and as
stats points out they did fire their
head trainer last year so they're at
least i think on notice that something's
not right there and uh if you're a 49ers
fan again if you're a fan of any team
you're holding your breath in the
preseason for the possibility of an
injury to a key player you don't want to
have that happen and for some teams
you're you're really holding your breath
because you've you've come to accept
that
it's just a matter of time before that
one injury happens it's going to derail
all of that optimism that you have built
into the run-up to the season and really
we're getting close to that point where
bubbles are going to start to pop
all off season long
plenty of
hope and plenty of excitement and plenty
of connecting at the dots to come to the
conclusion that hey this is the year
this could be the year and then reality
starts to set in in the preseason it
sets in with injury or maybe guys just
don't look very good and then when you
start piling up losses in september and
october
that's when that's when you start
thinking about next year when you get to
be zero and zero and be full of hope and
optimism all over again and that's one
of the things even though we have seen
the patriots essentially own the nfl for
the past generation with six super bowl
championships there's still a sense that
in any given year
any given team can't find their way to
the playoffs and we've seen it enough
times where a team
gets a spot low on the playoff tree and
runs the table that
it's stupid as it sounds and there isn't
a team this year that i would say has no
chance of making the playoffs in past
years i remember a year where i said the
raiders have no chance of making the
playoffs and then i worried oh my god
they're going to turn it around and make
me look like even more of an idiot than
i already am but they didn't that year
there was a year i said the browns have
no chance this year
there isn't a team that i can point at
and say that team has no chance some
would say miami i think under brian
flores they have a chance to at least
get lucky to at least put some wins
together build some confidence you know
every team is going to get better or
worse than they are right out of the
gates and we have seen teams get
dramatically better by the end of the
regular season and i don't think there's
a team out of the 32 uh that are in the
nfl that i would look at and say it's
impossible for them to get good enough
to steal one of the six playoff spots in
either conference by the time the dust
settles but that process begins tonight
of getting to
the preseason getting to see the rookies
getting to worry about injuries getting
to see football again the uniforms are
back out it's going to look like exactly
what it will look like in september it
just doesn't mean anything in the
standings but for now it's what we have
and we can't wait to see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports